what does your morning routine look like
at the moment morning routine is
wake up
if i
round about what time uh i'm waking up
these days around 6 a.m 6 30 a.m i'm
trying to go to sleep by about 10 30 p.m
sometimes it's 11 sometimes it's 10.
i wake up
um and i have to be careful here because
i whenever i've described my routine in
a little bit of detail people always say
i can't believe you don't go to the
bathroom that's like well of course i so
i
so i want to be clear i i take care of
my basic functions um but when i wake up
i make a bee line for sunlight
uh so i'm gonna get sunlight in my eyes
for the you know i'll probably go into
the grave saying this so forgive me if
people have heard me say this before but
the single best thing you can do for
your sleep your energy your mood your
wakefulness your metabolism is to get
natural light in your eyes early in the
day don't wear sunglasses to do it takes
about 10 minutes or so
um if you live in a cloudy area if
you're in the uk in the winter yes or
the summer or the summer maybe you
resort to some artificial light as a
replacement but
as much as one can get bright
natural and if not natural artificial
light in your eyes early in the day
without sunglasses
contacts and
eyeglasses are fine don't try and do it
through a window or windshield it's
going to take far too long this sets in
motion a huge number of different
neurobiological and and hormonal
cascades that are good for you reduces
stress late at night offsets cortisol a
million different things really that are
good for you so i get that
and yes somebody does that walk do a
little walk ideally that would be a walk
but sometimes we'll just go into the
yard and have some coffee and and
you know soak into whatever sunlight
through through the clouds if it's a
cloudy overcast day it might be 20 30
minutes if it's a
um it's a very bright day it might just
be a few minutes but really the the
quality studies on humans that have
looked at this say try and get as much
natural light as you can in the morning
hours whenever it is that that is for
you
especially the first three hours after
waking if you can work outside great if
you can get in your window because as
opposed to just in a dark conference
room that's better but if you can get
outside that would be fantastic so i i
get sunlight i hydrate i drink water and
then yerba mate is my favorite form of
coffee excuse me caffeine are you
waiting how long are you waiting for 90
to 120 minutes are you doing any salts
during that time are you taking any
electrolytes in i am a fan of water with
element before i had element packets i
would just take a little bit of sea salt
or pink salt your favorite element
flavor
i like them all there's one i don't like
i'm not a fan of the chocolate one but i
like it yeah some people love it my
podcast producer his wife loves that so
i give it to her the chocolate mint one
but um i like the raspberry the
um the citrus one i love that stuff
mango chili is if you open the mango
chili and breathed in shortly afterwards
it's like being pepper sprayed it's
absolutely insane it's like it's like
being blasted in the face but yeah i
mean that's that's just the best way
that cold glass of water and that first
thing in the morning and i mean it was
you who uh
reassured me of the what i thought was
bro science about your adenosine system
not being active for the first 90
minutes and if you're going to pump
caffeine onto that you're not really
actually acting on that your adrenal
system is the one that you need to be
looking at optimal you hydration all
that sort of stuff it's just such a good
way to start the day so okay we've got
um 90 minutes deep what have you been
doing in that you've had your light in
the eyes what have you been doing
between that and the yerba mata in 90
minutes
i do everything i can to
not do email not do social media and to
take care of a few critical tasks these
days i'm i have this obsession with
trying to do one
cognitively hard thing a day
one
and one physically hard thing a day now
does it not extreme physical not david
goggins level workouts or anything but
um
in that 90 minutes i'll typically try
and read a research article start to
finish or i'll work on a document that i
might be doing a grant or research paper
or planning a podcast or researching a
podcast i try and get my brain into kind
of a linear mode i try and narrow that
aperture
so i don't the distraction that's
created by social media and interactions
with others can kind of wick out into
the rest of the day so i'm not
necessarily trying to finish something
in that time but i try and do something
challenging i experience great
pleasure from
battling through something mentally
challenging but that's something that i
built up since my university years when
i was about you know 19 or so got
serious about school and
really started to
experience the the deep pleasure of like
i figured that out or like that was
really tough i don't always succeed but
that's what i'm doing in that hour to 90
minutes but i confess sometimes
we'll take a walk during that time and
maybe talk through some things that are
that are challenging you know or
sometimes i get lazy and and i'll miss a
day of that cognitive challenge then i
do caffeine about 90 to 120 minutes
after waking
and
even though i prefer to work out earlier
i generally will then do some sort of
physical workout i have a very
consistent routine i've done over 30
years where i weight train for 45 or
minutes to an hour every other day and
occasionally i take an extra day off and
occasionally due to travel or other
commitments i'll occasionally double up
two days and then take two days off yep
so it's really boring you know talk
about workout schedules but it's really
simple it's like you know i'll do a uh
kind of pushing day rest pulling day
upper body push up rest upper body pull
rest and then legs take two days off
something like that are you doing on the
off days are you doing some sort of zone
three
always jogging or skipping rope those
are my favorite forms of cardio
sometimes swimming but typically i'll go
running for 30 to 45 minutes or if i'm
feeling a little bit lazier because i
always find the high intensity stuff to
be easier than the long drawn out stuff
i'll sometimes throw on a weight vest a
30 or 50 pound weight vest and i'll go
out for a shorter run or i'll i'm a big
fan of knees over toes ben patrick i
know you had him oh yeah great we were
down in costa rica with him and his wife
who had the best time and learned so
much um i'll occasionally
um do a backwards you know he'll walk um
or throw on the weight vest for that um
we sometimes will get bands and we'll so
there's a great way to combine this we
will sometimes get two people in one of
these thick bands do hill walks in the
morning while getting our sunlight yeah
but that i don't really consider a
workout i consider that just kind of
rehabilitate as a movement so on the off
days i'm doing cardio and sometimes
that's the morning sometimes that's in
the evening i do not like to wait
training on the second half of the day
because i like to be really caffeinated
when i train i like to listen to loud
fast music
most of the time not always i keep my
phone
out or off of for most workouts
podcasts maybe if i'm running but i
really try hard when i'm working out to
just focus on the workout and those
workouts the weight training workouts
are always 10 minutes or so of warm up
and then no more than 40 to 50 minutes
of really hard work if i do train hard
any longer i don't recover enough to be
able to come in a few days later and
when i train that way i generally make
pretty consistent progress and you're
taking yourself up until what's up
probably maybe 10 30 11 a.m something
like that yeah and then i'll eat my
first real meal now occasionally i'll
wake up really hungry if i didn't eat
that well the night before but typically
the after i train i yeah i'll eat i like
oatmeal after i train oatmeal fruit some
fish oil protein drink and then maybe 90
to 120 minutes after that i'll have a
real lunch my lunch is pretty much the
biggest meal of the day if i have my way
it'll be a steak a salad maybe a little
more starch although i sort of got it
earlier um brazil nuts and that meal
sometimes can extend longer than life i
love being a feeding tube i love to eat
yeah so i'll eat and then i confess i
usually will work a little bit more for
about 30 minutes or an hour typically
email and then i'll take a um 10 to 30
minute yoga nidra nap or a nap
and then come back refreshed
um i really struggle with the naps when
i come back after that and my emotions
are all over the place i'm disoriented
maybe it's because
i struggle to fall asleep super quickly
and therefore i'm extending that period
out for a little bit longer than i need
i probably need to try the yoga nidra
thing but for me it's
i'm absolutely all over if i do that i
wake up and i don't know what day it is
and my emotions always feel a little bit
out of whack as well i wake up grumpy
from naps sometimes i'm told okay there
are a few times when i've woken up just
really angry i have no idea what that's
about i don't know any of the
neurochemistry associated with that
sometimes i wake up from naps it's
really pleasant i'll occasionally do if
the nap is early enough in the day
afterwards i'll have a you know a nice
double espresso and get back into work
that's the hardest part of the day
actually if i was well structured in the
early part of the day it's that 2 or 3
p.m the key is then to try and get
something really useful done cognitively
again so some people might look at this
and say wait you're working for an hour
in the morning and 30 minutes here and
an hour in the afternoon when are you
actually working but
it's really about the depth of the
trench when you're working and so if i'm
gonna drop into something again for a
few hours in the afternoon
i'm really going to drop into it and
that's typically phone off and out of
the room and my goal is to get to the
evening time so that i can do the things
that i want what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode
and don't forget to subscribe
peace